from a fan's perspective we didn't see
all of the internal issues going on
right yeah um
poc is like you said the biggest thing
moving
you know two of america's most wanted is
a song with poc and snoop on it that's
going crazy and that is good to be and
daz did the beat and and you know
and at the time there
the snoop and pok and sug weren't seeing
eye to eye you know what i'm saying like
what was that what was that what was
that era like of of of just just being
around snoop and dog pounds like this
[ __ ]
that was the error
period that's what it was [ __ ]
right it's crap
so at that like
was there ever a point in time was our
friend and when i say our i'm speaking
of the dog pound in general snoopy
dazz grub
you know what i'm saying and outlaws and
thug life psyching everybody you know
what i'm saying so they was all our
friends now the two heads of the horses
have an issue
you know
um
so you know eventually
they would have worked that out
you know what i'm saying right that's
what you know friends do tupac and
snoopy were real friends
you know what i'm saying and poc had his
issue
and snoopy was you know
i mean what's going to happen to snoop
right
nothing
if people are smart yeah you know what
i'm saying and
park didn't want to harm dog
you know what i'm saying
tupac love dog he was more disappointed
than anything
and you know
me and parker similar sometimes we bring
the carpet for the horse
you know what i'm saying and like those
records you hear
no that was pock he was filled with
anger
and he would let it go and those records
probably were never even recorded for us
to ever hear
obviously they were never officially
released like they ended up quarterly it
was recorded to be heard
you know but
it's just like me and dmx
you know what i'm saying
you know we
we got together
and um squashed our beef all right right
and we didn't even know each other
a snoop and tupac they knew each other
they were friends so that was
yeah that's what i'm saying so that
would have eventually been taken out the
water and
i doubt if pop would have
released those records about snoopy
you know what i'm saying but you never
know with tupac you know he was very
spontaneous and
he said what he meant you know what i'm
saying that was tupac